welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 7. and
remember the best way to watch these new
episodes of the walking dead is on amc
plus click the link in the description
to sign up now and join in for this epic
final season we start off with the
maggie and negan crew maggie still wants
to continue their mission to attack the
reapers and get her old settlement back
but negan's like yo our army is down to
four total people this mission's a
failure we gotta go home maggie's not
backing down though so negan sees an
opportunity he's like okay i'll make you
a deal if i help you beat the reapers i
want your promise that you're not gonna
kill me maggie's like fine whatever man
you got a deal and they shake on it so
they've reached a new level of
cooperation but the problem persists
that they're still way outnumbered but
maggie and negan have an idea they
realize they can use the walkers to
boost their numbers if they go zombie
mask whisperer style yes it's wild
maggie in a whisperer mask negan's
showing her the ropes remember he was
undercover with them for a while
eventually these two sit down and have a
talk they really actually get to the
core of some issues here that they've
been dancing around all season basically
negan's like yo i understand now from
your perspective back then i was the bad
guy to you the saviors were an evil gang
but i mean to me those were my people
but now things have changed you guys are
my new people so we got to put the past
behind us and you work together so
maggie's like hey if you knew what you
know now would you have done things
differently back then and this would be
a fantastic opportunity for negan to
actually give her a heartfelt apology
i'm sorry i killed glenn in front of you
that was actually awful but negan does
not say that he goes another way with it
he's like if i could do it all over
again i realized i should have killed
all of you so yeah these two are moving
forward but not friends yet meanwhile
daryl still undercover with the reapers
is out on a scouting mission with leah
now the reaper's leader pope seems
pretty unhinged but lee is still
fiercely loyal to him because you know
he got them through the zombie
apocalypse and stuff but daryl starts to
plant the seeds like hey maybe the
reapers are the bad guys when they find
some random family pope orders leah to
kill them but leah doesn't she lets them
go proven that she's still a pretty good
person father gabriel by the way goes on
a scouting mission he encounters the
reaper's priest so it's priest first
priest but they don't fight over at the
commonwealth our group is being punished
for breaking the rules by having to
clear out a bunch of zombies from
buildings on the outskirts king ezekiel
is clearly not doing well though
remember he's got the cancer so they're
like hey man get this guy to a hospital
yumiko is not being punished though she
wasn't with them when they broke the
rules in fact she's getting the vip
treatment the commonwealth seems to
really care about who you were before
the zombie apocalypse apparently their
governor pamela milton was also a
harvard grad so yumiko's being fast
fast-tracked for leadership so yumiko's
hanging out with her brother and she
brings up again hey man you were a
surgeon like why aren't you the doctor
here and he's like no don't tell anyone
i was a doctor i just like the simple
life of baking pies please it'll get me
in trouble but seems like he's already
in trouble cause a bunch of the
stormtroopers grab him take him away so
yumiko talks to lance hornsby who is
basically better call saul he's like
look your brother's fine it's
complicated political situation here you
want your friends who broke our rules
pardoned plus you want help for your
other group alexandria these are big
asks but seems like you're fast tracked
for leadership so i'm going to help you
out you just got to give me time so
lance warns me goes to the rest of our
groups with king ezekiel who just
received some first class medical
treatment he's like good work guys
you're almost done with your sentence
here eugene and stephanie just go to the
north fence and clear some more walkers
there now earlier we saw this real tulio
preppy preppy-looking kid getting a vip
escort for a picnic with his girlfriend
but this area is not secure some zombies
are coming for him luckily eugene and
stephanie are here just in time to save
them but this guy does not say thanks
for saving my life he's like hey you
guys interrupted my picnic the audacity
eugene's like oh hell nah i did not go
through the zombie apocalypse be told
off by this little prick and when he
insults stephanie eugene clocks him
right in the face but this was a bigger
deal than eugene realized this wasn't
just some random entitled prick he is
sebastian milton the governor pamela
milton's son and it seems like the
commonwealth has even more of a class
hierarchy than we realized eugene's in
big trouble now yumiko is actually about
to have a meeting with pamela milton
there's something special though about
her receptionist we actually met her
once before she was getting ice cream
when eugene was on his date with
stephanie she's suddenly asking imako
about her group there may be more to her
than we know but anyway now after the
face punching incident timoko's meetings
postponed so eugene is now in
commonwealth jail for real and lance
orangebee's like hey man you're never
getting out of here unless you gotta
give us the location of your settlement
alexandria eugene's like no way can't do
it you could roll up in full force and
wipe them out but this guy's like hey
we're not perfect but do we seem like we
do that we've treated you guys
relatively very fairly and so eugene
cracks he tells him where alexandria is
so now at the end of the episode maggie
and crew have really gotten the hang of
walking with the walkers they stopped by
a boarded up building which has a ton
more inside oh she's builded up a pretty
good horde and so maggie and negan
whisper style the new alpha and beta
plus maggie's one other surviving friend
who had a very mini plot where his
sister died they're leading their own
zombie horde to attack their reapers and
that's where the episode comes to an end
episode 8 is the finale of this first
part of the final season it's gonna be
an action-packed episode you want to
watch it and you know the way to do it
is on amc plus stream every new episode
ad free from any device plus get early
access to the new episodes the week
before right now the annual plan is just
4.99 a month so click that link in the
description and sign up now join in for
this epic final season of the walking
dead
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you love
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member